Michael Díaz Rivera espero haberse
beneficiado con la decisión del
presidente Joe biden la indultar a miles
de estadounidenses condenados por simple
posesión de marihuana Michael tenía 19
años cuando fue detenido y esto le ha
acarreado problemas para conseguir
vivienda y trabajo sí Ahora puedo
respirar hondo cuando pienso en mi
condena Y en todo lo que he superado
porque me ha causado muchos disgustos y
traumas a lo largo de los años
unas 6.500 personas que tienen condenas
previas podrían verse favorecidas por la
orden ejecutiva Aunque el indulto no
cubre las condenas por posesión de otras
drogas o por cargos relacionados con la
producción o posesión de marihuana con
intención de distribuirla en diferentes
estados hay partidarios de la iniciativa
presidencial
creo que es impresionante en realidad
porque aunque la marihuana es una droga
también creo que no se debe pagar cárcel
por ellos
si el alcohol se legaliza a los
cigarrillos se legalizan ya sabes como
que hacen más daño internamente Así que
siento que la gente que está en la
cárcel por ese tipo de cosas debería
estar libre
tras el anuncio presidencial las
acciones de cultivadores y vendedores se
dispararon según estimaciones la
industria mundial del Cannabis alcanzará
en 2026 los 55 mil millones de dólares
en ventas en Estados Unidos estas cifra
será de 40 mil millones según las
proyecciones de la empresa bdsa la
decisión de biden ha sido vista como una
estrategia política de Cara a las
elecciones de medio término